what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with inferno magneto versus
nimrod and it's really more magneto and
charles xavier versus nimrod and the
fight is epic
it's ridiculously epic okay so here's
the funny thing this is the conclusion
of inferno and initially i forgot that
it was four issues long right like i got
to the end of the story and i was like i
mean this is weird this is a weird way
to end the comic like it feels like it's
over right then i looked it up and i was
like well that's because it is over
right because marvel does so many six
issue stories now that it's almost kind
of weird when they drop a four issue
series and like that's it right it just
kind of takes you by surprise but in the
last video that we did we basically
covered this to cover the segment and
really cover the events where
essentially destiny and mystique had
gotten their hands on warren mctaggart
they had taken her we didn't know
exactly how they did it we simply just
knew that they had and the result of
this is that xavier and magneto were led
into a trap where they believed more
mctaggart had been taken where they
believed that mystique and destiny were
holding more image haggar which was on
the orcis forge and so as soon as
magneto and xavier teleport here they're
immediately met by the arrival of all
these orcis forces now once all that
stuff pops off right once everything
happens here it gets kind of crazy
because you had a kind of conversation
between magneto and and xavier well
remember magneto can gently lift his
helmet and he can overhear the
telepathic thoughts of xavier anything
short of that and xavier won't be able
to get in right magneto won't be able to
hear anything xavier is saying
telepathically the result of this is
that they kind of have this quick bit of
a discussion where they're like that's
nimrod right like nimrod is alive and
well i mean they kind of knew he was
alive and well but as you guys know when
it comes to somebody like nimrod there's
a big difference between hearing he's
alive having it reported to you that
he's alive and standing in front of
nimrod right because as we know nimrod
killed apocalypse right at one of the
different lifespans of mora mctaggart
nimrod killed apocalypse this is no
small thing right this guy is literally
a living weapon he can he can determine
what your powers are and then basically
develop the systems he needs to
essentially counter them or even negate
your powers but the crazy thing about
this is that you have this kind of thing
where omega right remember she's
basically kind of like a future version
of herself or at least a version from
the timeline where she's there to
basically make sure that the war pops
off the way that it's supposed to and
the rise of the machines actually take
place right so like the sentinel program
develops as it's supposed to all of
which will basically lead to this moment
and then presumably in the future uh the
idea of machines conquering humanity and
the mutant population and so when you
have one of the orcas agents who says
like like this is your last chance to go
the response to nimrod is like do you
guys not realize the look in these guys
eyes in the eyes of xavier and magneto
they're ready to die right they're ready
to die for their cause and the orcas
ages response is so would we and the
responsible mega is and so you have and
literally like nimrod and omega
eradicate every single orgas agent here
right they kill them all like that it
happens so fast none of these guys ever
had a chance the reason behind why they
did this is because omega and nimrod
hate humanity and the reason why they
hate humanity is remember that while
omega is still more of a cyborg than she
is a pure human she allies herself more
with a machine than she does with their
biological components nimrod is just
full-on machine right he's literally an
artificial intelligence that has
basically gained uh gained you know
sentience right gained its own level of
self-awareness and operates according to
essentially ensuring that the mutant
population is destroyed but throughout
the entire history of humanity's use of
machines they were tools right that's
the thing that this really kind of said
here by by omega is like they're tools
and it's one of these funny things is
because from their perspective and it's
almost one of these things we're hitting
kind of toys with the idea of like
skynet right terminator that kind of a
thing the whole idea behind like the
animatrix the war between like man and
machine this notion that like robots can
basically have feelings right they they
can experience sadness and anger and
pain and so on and so forth now of
course in in model comics machines are
very very human in terms of how they're
depicted the only real exception to that
are like sentinels but the important
thing here is that humanity has always
viewed and used machines as tools but
machines themselves right nimrod being
used as a tool to destroy the mutant
population so on and so forth right it
basically pisses them off they've hated
humanity because of it and so that
really seems to be and really seems to
be the basis behind why it is that the
machine population waged a war against
humans and mutants and it's why it looks
like in that far-flung future humanity
basically had to merge with like
proto-humans right like the next stage
of human evolution those individuals who
were locked away in the vault right we
saw those they escaped four time and
then basically they went back in again
right those guys right why humanity had
to merge with them because it was the
only way for humanity to survive that in
the face of a war between super advanced
technology and mutants who could have
powers ranging from the ability to read
minds spanning all the way up to
controlling the entire earth's
electromagnetic spectrum humanity was
powerless there was basically nothing
they could do especially when the one
weapon they did have which was machines
turned on them right and so you get this
crazy thing because at that point like
literally magneto just grabs a giant
satellite just brings it crashing down
on them which both of them knew nothing
was gonna happen because of that right
you're gonna it's a hard sell to get
anyone to believe that that nimrod could
be killed by a multi-ton piece of just
machinery that's never going to happen
and in fact omega and and nimrod both
escape the entire thing and like the
fight basically begins to break out now
at that point xavier and really what
he's trying to do here is find where
maura mctaggart is right i mean they
want to escape with their lives but they
also realize the longer this fight goes
on for the higher the likelihood they
are going to die because the reality is
while magneto is powerful and while
xavier is powerful they're not on the
level of power they need to defeat
people like omega or nimrod right they
just don't have that level of power and
so you get this kind of crazy moment
here where xavier just like freaks out
lashes out and attacks nimrod and just
lets off this massive burst of psychic
energy which actually shatters nimrod's
entire brain now on that surface right
there you would think that he would be
killed but before we find out you
actually switch directly over to uh to
mystique and to destiny the reason being
is because while more mctaggart's here
remember they've got a vendetta their
desire is to kill maura mctaggart and so
when they're here down in this place
below krakow literally a gun is pulled
by mystique and when the question of
mormon taggart is are you really gonna
kill me right you realize if you kill me
the entire universe will will start over
again a new timeline will be created you
will have forgotten all of this maybe
destiny could come back and maybe
destiny will remember it all we won't
know for sure but everything that's
happened here will be obliterated and
the responsibility is yes and she pulls
the trigger and everything fades right
everything just blips and like that's it
at that point you jump back right to the
initial conversation that was that took
place between emma frost and mystique
and destiny we didn't know exactly what
tools emma frost had given to mystique
and destiny to help them achieve their
goal of capturing more mctaggart and
then presumably killing more mctaggart
and being able to do it all without
charles xavier or magneto realizing what
their intention was what you end up
finding out here is that with this whole
thing going on because their goal is to
kill maura of course emma says the same
thing if you kill her you will restart
reality you cannot kill her as long as
she is a mutant that cannot be allowed
to happen and so at that point mystique
just kind of kind of starts to realize
what it is that mystique is saying if
she says forge once told me about the
worst weapon he ever made a gun that
turns us into them that makes a mutant
human but i saw the look in his eyes he
would never give that to us willingly he
would never ever ever do that and that's
when emma frost presents the gun right
she says yes how to find maura and what
to do with her once you have and so what
you end up finding out here this is the
craziest thing what you end up finding
out here is that every instance where
maura mctaggart was basically taken by
mystique right everything that had to
happen in order for that to take place
it was all orchestrated by mystique who
was shape-shifting right it was all
orchestrated by her shape-shifting into
people switching from one person to the
next right creating descent and
confusion among the ranks of orcas
driving them to attack each other and
then tricking nimrod and omega into
fighting charles xavier and magneto
right literally mystique orchestrated
all of it now here's the reason why that
matters right over the years and really
in more recent years just the the
overall dangerous nature of mystique has
fallen to the wayside and a lot of
that's because marvel never really did
anything meaningful with her right she
was just there and marvel kept her
around because she was a legacy
character right she'd been a legacy
character since the days of chris
claremont she'd been a legacy character
since like the old school x-men days
she'd been a legacy character she's
actually the animated series right i
mean she'd just been around that long
that she was a character you just
couldn't really kill off for any real
measure of time but there was nothing
really ever done with her that really
illustrated how capable she was what
this does right here is show you just
how dangerous mystique is right if the
world does not succumb to complete and
total nuclear catastrophe it's because
mystique allowed it like that's really
how dangerous she is at any point in
time mystique can impersonate a sitting
president and then press the button and
just launch a nuclear arsenal at another
country and there goes the world that's
the nature of mystique right you could
quite literally craft a story where
mystique kills the marvel universe and
it would be believable right she's that
capable and it's so great to see
jonathan hickman just like do her
character justice right it's just it's
so great to see somebody who's not like
yeah there's a mistake she's a person
there no to be like no man like mystique
dude she's on a whole different level
right this girl has been around for for
quite some time she's almost as old as
wolverine is uh and she is stupidly
dangerous right and so that's when you
have this kind of crazy thing where
basically mystique reveals tomorrow
mctaggart we made you human right like
we made you a human and that's it and so
that's what more is like that's your
plan it's like take my powers away and
then kill me like that's that's that's
it and so that's when warren mctaggart
basically spills the beans it says you
hardly understand what's going on here
right like your your desire to kill me
here is because of some vendetta where
i've basically been messing with
timelines and stuff like that and like
you set me on fire right and i'm like
i've been hiding from you with so on and
so i was like you think you understand
what's going on you have no clue this
timeline right this whole this whole
timeline that i've created where i i
basically drove xavier and magneto to
form the quiet council to build the
nation of krakowa from their perspective
i'm saving the mutant population the
reality is i don't care anything about
krakowa i don't care anything about the
mutants on krakowa right i have lived
these lives a thousand times i have seen
this happen so many times and every time
it ends the same way it ends in a war
between the human population and the
mutant population and the machine
population and humans sometimes merge
with the post-human race and sometimes
they're destroyed by the post-human race
and all that's left are post-humans and
machines and mutants but no matter how
it happens no matter what takes place no
matter how it unfolds mutants always die
we always get destroyed every single
time without fail that's what happens
there's no way to stop that if any
timeline is created out there that
allows the mutant population to
propagate long enough we will be
obliterated the reason why i created
krakowa the reason why i orchestrated
xavier and magneto doing this forming
the quiet council and consolidating the
entire mutant population down is so i
could destroy it so that what i could do
is quite literally start manipulating
things behind the scenes so that kids
who were born on krakowa are born
without powers that i would basically
neutralize them this gun you have in
your hand it's a basic simple thing
right it takes the powers away from a
person i aim for mutant genocide i aim
to set things up so that there will
never be mutants who are born again
right so this war between the mutant
population and any other populations out
there will never come to fruition the
mutant race will survive because the
mutant race will not exist all of us
will be made into humans that was the
goal of maura mctaggart and it's just
like damn son like she was basically
boxing the mutant population in so she
could wipe out the mutant population
that's nuts right basically we would
sterilize the mutant gene in the mutant
population and that would be it and it's
just like okay like this is crazy like
this is this is absolutely nuts and so
at that point you switch over to to
professor x and you switch over to
magneto right now here's here's a crazy
thing that goes on here magneto was
playing possum with omega right like
charles xavier hits up magneto and says
we're running out of time we have to
find maura and magneto says yes i know
charles we will right and that's when
when he asked omega like you heard him
didn't you right we have a question that
we want to answer and the answer of
omega is you shouldn't worry about him
you should worry about yourself and the
response of magneto is no you should
worry about me and like seizes the
mechanical components of omega right
like this
man
oh man
this is about to get nuts on okay here's
what they use
dude it's it's
mad y'all are not prepared right so so
here's the thing while all that's going
on right like like remember like
literally like xavier destroyed the head
of of nemo but remember nimrod can
reconstitute himself and this is a far
more advanced version right remember the
original nimrod is referred to as nimrod
the lesser this was referred to as
nimrod the greater he's more powerful
and he can regenerate faster right this
guy is designed to just be an absolute
wrecking machine and that's literally
what happens is it's like like as
magneto is basically interrogating omega
by pulling her machine components off of
her body that immediately as soon as
nimrod reconstitutes he grabs xavier and
that's when he tells magneto he was just
like we don't have time for this right
like here's the thing to understand you
probably need this guy as much as i need
her so you have to ask yourself how much
will others have to pay when your
actions put their lives on the line now
the crazy thing here is xavier basically
tells magneto no we should leave like we
should leave here right now they will
kill us if we stay but magneto won't he
won't give he's like no that's not going
to happen like i'm not giving it up like
like there's no circumstance where you
leave here alive niron right now
nimrod's whole thing is if you let her
go i will let him go we'll call today a
draw will go our separate ways and so
essentially it's kind of nimrod and
xavier who are somewhat on the same side
here where it's like magneto let them go
right and it's one of those crazy things
right now he knows i hear this machine i
have lost everything multiple times so i
am well conditioned to accept some small
losses for greater gains and so because
of the fact that nimrod's basically told
i will do i will die and destroy you
here before i let anything else go on in
this place the response of nimrod is
fine then ultimately this is a grudge
between you and me so then we'll make it
a grudge between you and me right like i
will let them go i will let xavier go
and and you will let omega go and then
you will like they will leave they'll
get out of here and then it'll just come
down to you and me and so the response
of magnetos what do you want me to do
charles right now this is very very
important right charles says they don't
have mora mctaggart eric she's somewhere
else that knowledge will die with us we
have to try you have to trust them right
like if we die here right now we will
not remember where maura mctaggart is
like all this information that we've
gained here we won't recall and so we'll
basically have to start this search all
over again and so when terminator's like
fine i'd agree i agree to your terms
release him and the response of nimrod i
am so sorry you trusted me flat and it
just totally eradicates xavier at that
point magneto loses it just totally
loses it just just freaks out just
totally crushes omega right and then at
that point goes after nimrod but
remember nimrod can duplicate and so at
that point it's just creating duplicates
of himself right and so it's literally
magneto fighting two nimrods and it is
crazy because while that's going on
omega is still somewhat alive right it's
still like she's still somewhat there
man here's here's a great thing man
magneto's holding his own against two
nimrods man that's no small thing right
like like understand a nimrod killed
apocalypse magneto's holding his own
against two right it's it's crazy to see
this happening right now here's the
kicker behind all this omega's not dead
right i mean her body's basically ripped
to pieces she's all over the damn place
but she can still communicate with her
psychic components and at that point
like literally she says like i have
something special for you mutant a
surprise a power dampener activates it
and shuts off the magnetic abilities of
of magneto as soon as that happens here
comes nimrod and it's wow nimrod takes
out magneto and at that point omega
reconstitutes herself and then like
literally magneto's just kind of laying
there right he's like this is not over
right like there's no way this is this
is over right we're gonna keep going
like we're gonna keep fighting and the
response to them is like no right and
they literally blow the whole place up
right they just detonate the whole spot
and magneto's like i will see you again
right and the responsible mega is of
course you will mutant it's inevitable
right it's inevitable we will meet again
we will see you in the future and when
that war comes we'll destroy you then
too at that point switch back over to
mystique and to uh into more mctaggart
and destiny right just crazy ass thing
so you have this whole conversation
going on right where it's like okay so
the goal of of more mctaggart here was
to basically sterilize the mutant
population over the course of a couple
generations and then basically ensure
that the mutant population had no powers
by the time this war came to fruition
right and so basically they're just like
let's kill her right let's just kill her
and be done with it enter douglas ramsey
right cypher now remember cypher's been
watching all of this and that was one of
the things that was established right
this is why jonathan hickman writing is
so important is because things that were
referenced a couple issues ago or things
that were referenced a year and a half
ago are incredibly important by the time
you get to the end and so to kind of
reiterate here one of the things that
we've learned is that as soon as doug
ramsey was contacted by professor xavier
to visit the island of krakowa and to
basically find a way to turn that place
into a kind of a refuge for the mutant
population cypher never never believed
in xavier i mean he believed in him but
didn't believe him right he thought that
there was something else going on he's
like i've i've been a new mutant i've
been an x-man i've been a part of the
mutant community long enough to know
that xavier is not the most trustworthy
person out there and so working
alongside warlock and basically the
island of cocoa itself that where where
uh the the hub of moore mctaggart was
created and it was basically gonna be
hidden from the eyes of everybody except
for those who could access it douglas
ramsey used the power of warlock to
basically create a kind of back door for
himself so he could witness everything
that was going on so every single
conversation that had ever transpired
between warren mctaggart and xavier and
magneto everything else that was
everything was supposed to be hidden
from the mutant population where no one
was supposed to know what was actually
going on cypher knew it douglas ramsay
knew it and then for for a really
interesting reason that's not that this
doesn't seemingly seem to be made clear
that douglas ramsey believes in krakowa
even if he doesn't necessarily believe
in in the ideologies or the philosophies
of xavier and magneto and especially not
maura mctaggart he believes in what can
happen here on kakoa and he's been
watching all this unfold and so as soon
as he arrives he basically says okay
here's the thing mystique you could kill
mora mctaggart but here's the problem i
believe in the laws that we have here
and what's the first law of krakowa
murder no man you have made more
mctaggert a human now you intend to kill
them you intend to violate one of the
most sacred laws of krakowa which is not
to kill a human without that human
having been put on trial or to simply
just not kill them at all right these
laws that you fashioned for the rest of
the mutant population now you're going
to break them themselves is that how it
is right like the rules are for thee not
for me right is that i mean are you read
it why do you create rules everybody
else has to follow but you don't follow
them yourself is that really what this
is and so at that point that's when
destiny chimes in because we're mistakes
like well i mean okay fine we could just
kill you and be done with it right like
we could just kill you right here right
and then you can be reborn and you'll
never remember any of this doug ramsey
you'll never recall any of what happened
here because i sit on the quiet council
and i can manipulate behind the scenes
and determine what it is that you do and
do not recall right corruption of the
highest order but at that point doug
ramsey's like i mean that's possible but
what about all of them and that's when
he brings in right bay the blood moon
his wife from the ten of swords event
you guys remember that she's wildly
deadly there's no way mystique could
take on bae right i mean that's just
that's never going to happen mystique is
capable but she's not going to kill this
girl right and then there's just the
whole island of krakowa which at any
point in time could just expel the
mutant population just be like you're
all out of here right everybody leave
right literally evict them from their
own home like it's any one of these
things and so at that point there's no
way mystique could basically kill doug
ramsey without her actions being made
public and then she'd essentially be
confined to the pit for pretty much for
all eternity just sitting down there
with sabertooth and so as a result to
this that's when destiny chimes in and
says no here's the thing if you kill
doug right now yo you'll basically be
confined right that'll it'll be the end
of you i will remain on the quiet
council but i will die six months later
and that douglas ramsey will basically
remain in his current position right
that he'll be reborn and that everybody
will know what you did everything will
go on and like literally for you and i
we lose for everybody else they win and
then the question is well then what do
we do about maura mctaggart and the
response of destiny is mormon tiger's
future it fluxes wildly right it
branches who knows what's going to
happen here right like we have no clue
what's going to happen with her
character all we know is that she's
human now so whatever world is out there
for her she's going to have to just
figure it out on her own and so in turn
doug ramsey's like okay your life is
saved more mctaggart but understand
you're now exiled you can never come
back to the to the nation of kokoa like
literally cocoa will let you use this
gate one final time but as soon as you
pass through this game all gates to the
mutant nation of kokoa will be closed to
you right it'll give you a head start
and so in turn you have like this kind
of amazing statement that's made by
mystique right where she says like you
have what you've always wanted more mma
tagger you have your humanity enjoy it
while you can enjoy it while you run
right the response of mistake is like
we're going to find you and we're going
to kill you make no mistake mystique and
destiny would forgo their inclusion as
part of the quiet council to kill maura
mctaggart but also understand warmth
tiger will be out there in the world
there's nowhere she can go where she can
hide from mystique and destiny one even
if destiny wasn't here mystique's
capable enough has enough resources and
enough contacts she could find her but
two destiny being here she's a precock
she would ultimately be able to find out
where mormont tagger is somewhere along
the line right as more mctaggart's
future becomes more clear they would
ultimately be able to locate her and so
because of that like her days are
numbered it's only a matter of time
before maura mctaggart dies and so
picking up one week after all of this
magneto and professor xavier are brought
back and when the questions asked how
much time has passed right how long has
it been the response of emma frost is
long enough for things to change
especially those which needed it most
and so when xavier asked like what have
you done emma she says exactly what you
would have done charles something quite
radical i told the entire quiet council
everything that had happened i told them
about morgan mctaggart i told them about
your secret meetings with morgan
mctaggart i told them everything you had
kept hidden from them but here's the
irony of this the choir council
seemingly agreed that charles xavier and
magneto keeping these secrets from the
rest of the mutant population was the
right thing the mistake was keeping
those secrets from the quiet council now
here's an important distinction to
understand right let's say that like
nasa with their advanced telescopes and
all that kind of stuff figured out that
a meteor was coming to earth and it was
going to crash into the earth in the
next like three years right like it was
on a collision course it was going to
hit the world it was going to wipe out
all life on the planet the question you
have to ask is should humanity be told
the correct answer to that question is
no you do not tell the rest of humanity
why because humanity will do the only
thing it knows how to do in a time of
desperation it will panic and when that
happens it'll just create chaos right
literally humanity will destroy the
world before the meteor does that's
exactly what's going to happen that
human beings cannot be trusted with the
knowledge of their impending death right
the humanity has consistently time and
time and again shown that it cannot
handle that kind of information if the
quiet council had revealed all of this
to the entire mutant population it would
have destroyed everything right it would
have destroyed everything that had
happened right and it probably would
have led to some kind of a civil war
among the mutant population that civil
war would have spread out into the rest
of the world and then all warmongering
eyes would have fallen on the nation of
kokoa and literally the mutant
population would have brought about its
own destruction because some kind of
conflict somewhere would have led to the
shores of some human nation somewhere
and would have inflicted catastrophic
damage right i mean you guys remember
the events of civil war when nitro
detonated in stanford connecticut and
that initiated the the passage of
sweeping legislation regarding the
ability for superheroes to act with
their identities being kept private and
so at the end of the day the quiet
council agrees this information will
stay with us right the quiet council is
a curse as much as it is a burden now
right like the information that you have
is now our information we have to go
forward essentially knowing that our own
doom is impending and we have to try to
find some way to keep that from
happening and so what this does is this
ends jonathan hickman's work on the
x-men what it looks like after this i
have no clue but jonathan hickman's gone
right he's done he's actually been gone
for marvel for a little while now right
he's working on three what is it three
world three moons whatever it is with
like scott snyder and all those guys so
he's doing his own thing but like right
now uh yeah hickman's run is finished
hitler's work is done at this point who
knows like we know we have jerry conway
writing x-men right now but who knows
how the x-men landscape is going to look
it could be in two years mama just sets
everything back to the way it was before
and goes back to writing crappy x-men
stories
who knows but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace